economía en directo américa de france 24
una semana más y empezamos hoy lunes
daniela blandón está con nosotros como
siempre danny como le fue fin de semana
descanso muy bien raúl muy musical el
fin de semana música con un concierto de
ricardo montaner qué rico muy
bueno hablemos ahora de lo que nos
importa en este momento que es por
supuesto la economía la unión europea
escucha esta semana sin embargo o no si
se embargaron o perdona el petróleo ruso
está desconcentrado estudios
concentradas que pensé en la cima del
cielo de mantener y me encanta y pero ya
soy un concierto de personas de la edad
de nosotros raúl ahora si vamos al grano
este lunes se lleva a cabo una reunión
de ministros de energía del bloque
comunitario de la unión europea para
discutir sobre un posible embargo
petrolero contra rusia y es que para
estos países es muy difícil raúl tomar
decisiones debido a que la dependencia
de la unión europea de rusia es del 40
por ciento si hablamos del gas natural y
del 26 por ciento si hablamos de
petróleo pero todo depende del país por
ejemplo hungría y eslovaquia compran un
96 y un 57 por ciento de su petro en la
nación ex soviética por eso la comisión
europea está analizando si es posible
dejarlos por fuera del veto y alemania
cree que podría hacerle frente a una
suspensión de envíos de petróleo ruso
pero no de gas natural escuchamos si
estaba a punto de ocurrir un embargo
petrolero general no lo sé escucho cosas
diferentes otros países aún no lo pueden
hacer y creo que eso debería respetarse
siempre he presentado la posición de
alemán haya presionado para que se
comprenda la posición de alemania por
ejemplo sobre el gas donde tampoco
podríamos hacerlo todavía también aplica
para otros países los pasos que vemos
deben ser inteligentes para no
desencadenar catástrofes económicas
porque actuamos sin pensar
danny los turcos tuvieron un difícil
ramadán este año por culpa de la
inflación no claro que sí pues termina
este mes sagrado del islám y muchos
tuvieron que vivirlo de una manera
diferente en este país todo por cuenta
de este estrepitoso repunte de la
inflación adriana rocha nuestro
corresponsable en ese país nos cuenta
detalles en el siguiente informe
[Música]
desde hace más de 100 días magnet sus
compañeros acampan delante de la fábrica
de donde fueron despedidos hace unos
meses por pedir mejoras salariales
cuando comenzó a subir la inflación en
turquía desde que me echaron hemos
dejado de comprar cosas que no sean
estrictamente necesarias por ejemplo un
vestido para mi hija ahora compro uno en
vez de dos o si hace calor los niños aún
llevan la ropa de invierno porque no
podemos comprarla de verano es muy
difícil
oficialmente la inflación turca se sitúa
en el 61 por ciento pero estudios
independientes la ubican en 143 por
ciento turquía no veía cifras parecidas
desde principios de la década de los
2000 y esa crisis económica le sirvió a
recep tayip erdogán para conseguir el
poder la crisis actual sin embargo
podría ser mucho más complicada abertis
getting best todo cada vez está peor el
gobierno intenta solucionar el problema
con eslóganes
pero esto no ayuda a los estómagos de la
gente que la gente necesita comprar
fruta necesidades básicas carne verdura
harina etcétera
witt en florecer la educación de su
familia están en ramadán pero este año
no tienen en su despensa tanta comida
como en otros tiempos para alimentarse
después de los ayunos
estamos en el mes de ramadán y ya queda
poco para romper el ayuno he llegado a
casa y en mirado que había
hoy haremos sopa de lentejas rojas
famosa en turquía y que además es
sencilla y fácil de hacer
ebro y su marido ganan el salario mínimo
hasta hace unos años les valía para
vivir sin apuros ahora con la inflación
desbocada sufren día a día y como muchos
han tenido que cambiar su estilo de vida
antes las niñas comían carne dos veces
por semana este mes no compramos porque
están ayudando intentamos comprar algo
de pollo pero solo podemos una vez cada
diez días
ante la espiral inflacionaria el
gobierno de recep tayyp erdogán ha
reducido los precios de la electricidad
y de los alimentos básicos pero estas
medidas no han sido suficientes para
magnet quien aún sin trabajo ha tenido
que endeudarse para poder sacar adelante
a sufrir y no mama hasta nueva zelanda
daniela porque ya finalmente los
turistas pueden entrar ese país tener
médico eso frecuente de la pandemia no
dan y ya podemos ir allá a raúl este
país aplicó una de las políticas de
confinamiento más estrictas del mundo a
partir de este lunes después de dos años
los turistas dos turistas vacunados
podrán circular libremente por el país
sin tener que hacer cuarentenas aunque
deben sí someterse a dos pruebas rápidas
para detectar el hobbit 19 el primer y
el quinto día si dan positivo los
contagiados deben aislarse por siete
días pero de todas maneras pueden
quedarse claro pero imagínense cuando
tiene que volar ese viaje si no duro
positivo y cuánto se tarda para llegar a
nueva zelanda
total dan y gracias por toda la
información nos vemos más adelante con
más economía pasamos ahora a ver a
nuestro reportaje